[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
vague épidémique en outre-mer
territorialisée les réponses amplifier
le soutien
le constat est alarmant
les autres maires représentent 4% de la
population française
et pourtant les territoires ultramarins
ont enregistré plus de 30% des décès
liés aux qu'ovide survenu en milieu
hospitalier entre juillet et octobre
face à cette situation la mission
commune d'information destiné à évaluer
les effets des mesures de restrictions
sanitaires présidée par bernard jomier
et dont jean michel arnaud et roger
karoutchi sont les rapporteurs a
consacré un travail spécifique à la
gestion de la crise dans ces territoires
malgré une multiplication des capacités
de réanimation l'envoi massif de
renforts
4600 soignants en trois mois et plus de
150 évacuations sanitaires vers
l'hexagone les hôpitaux ont été débordés
et les réanimations saturé
les sénateurs ont constaté que les
mesures de freinage différenciée selon
les territoires ont permis de revenir à
une situation globalement sous contrôle
néanmoins le taux de vaccination est
partout inférieur à celui de l'hexagone
excepté à saint pierre et miquelon
en guyane et aux antilles à l'exception
de saint barthélémy une majorité de la
population n'est pas vacciné et la vague
meurtrière de l'été dernier n'a provoqué
aucune accélération de la vaccination
la force de l'activisme anti vaccinales
et les appréhensions d'une part
importante de la population en limiter
la portée d'une communication demeurer
institutionnelle d'une campagne
vaccinale n'ayant que tardivement donné
lieu à des actions de proximité comme
les vaccine bus
afin d'anticiper une cinquième vague
épidémique la mission d'information
préconise de maintenir autant que
possible les renforts actuelle
elle suggère d'apporter un appui
technique aux instances locales pour
effectuer un retour d'expérience et
améliorer les plans de préparation aux
crises notamment la coordination avec
les professionnels libéraux
le rapport met en évidence l'importance
de renforcer l'autonomie des territoires
ultramarins en termes d'équipements de
matériels de produits de santé de
production d'oxygène
elle souligne enfin la nécessité de
rehausser les infrastructures
hospitalières et de renforcer
l'attractivité médicale
dans un second volet le rapport fait
état de nombre de fragilité structurelle
des économies d'autres mères qui
accentue l'impact de la crise épidémique
les acteurs alerte sur le fait que les
spécificités ultramarines ne sont pas
suffisamment prises en compte dans le
déploiement des aides et le plan de
relance
la mission d'information propose ainsi
d'assouplir et adapter les critères
d'éligibilité aux aides de simplifier
les démarches et d'allonger la durée du
soutien
ces solutions devraient permettre aux
outre-mer de préparer la reprise
économique tout en faisant face à une
éventuelle reprise épidémique
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]